in 2016 one year after the mass die-off
of saiga antelopes
a team of researchers returned to the
kazakh steppe
they wanted to find out how many saiga
had survived
the scientists spent days searching the
bedpage for the few remaining animals
this conservation area about the size of
france
was previously home to 240 000 saiga
of which 200 000 died
it wasn't easy for expedition leader
stefan souter to return to this place of
death
i was really shocked when i saw how many
animals were dying back in 2015.
was in the field myself and saw with my
own eyes the first dead saiga lying
there
it was the first place where it happened
and i was right there
that fantastic
huge mounds of earth where thousands of
animals were buried
still testified to the die-off along
with the countless bleached bones
lying among the low bushes
british veterinarian and antelope expert
richard [ __ ]
also witnessed the disaster that was
triggered by bacteria
the idea that the bacteria is present in
the animals and we have confirmed that
it does occur in healthy animals
and it overloads it something triggers
the growth of the bacteria and it kills
the saiga
the second hypothesis um is actually
more of an environmental source
of uh pasteuri which uh are ingested by
the animal
uh causing an overload and and this
would require an amoeba this is a
different organism
which is infected by the bacteria and
then at that wet season
period in may may become active the
bacteria become active and so the
grazing animals
in injustice and die as a consequence
at the time the expedition members
feared it would lead to the total
extinction of the saiga antelope
but what happened amazed everyone a baby
boom
in this step
that's because at the age of one females
usually bear one calf
as they age they tend to have twins
and older larger females may have
triplets
that means they invest a lot in the
production of offspring
and that allows the populations to
recover very very quickly
even after catastrophic events like in
2015.
the researchers now estimate the number
of saiga at
again as many as before the mass die off
the joy the many offspring bring is
offset by concern
the saiga are slowly returning to the
area where the mass die off began
could death still be lurking there in
the grass
the possibility of this occurring again
is very high
and the the question is simply when
and exactly what the trigger factors
will be but we can be
reasonably certain this will relate to
to weather
it may be driven by climate so the the
frequencies if you like of
of climate-related events which drive
humidity
temperature and then influence either
the bacteria
in the animal or the bacteria in the
environment
it will happen again i have no doubt
but human beings also pose a huge threat
to the saga
poachers hunt the animals for sale to
china where their horns are considered
to have healing properties
the saiga's habitat is also shrinking
there are three large populations of
saiga in kazakhstan
the ural group in the west of the
country the austria
group on the border with uzbekistan and
the largest bed pak dala in the centre
of the country
the saiga herds move back and forth
during the year
the kaza government wants to build a
highway between the caspian sea and the
kazakh capital nur sultan
passing right through bedpak dala even
though there's an alternative route
further north
they wouldn't even approach the road
anymore
even if they weren't completely
prevented from crossing they would at
least
be stopped for a while and their natural
cycle of migration
would be disrupted
right now only a few sandy tracks cross
through the step
they don't pose a problem for the saiga
but the pressure on the animals is
increasing
the saiga survived the holocene
extinction
so it's a pretty tough animal but
whether it can survive the human
uh anthropocene extinctions i'm afraid
is
is pretty marginal i think so we have a
number of factors coming up
you know it uh you know the change in
human
impact on the environment directly you
know we'll just complicate this further
for the moment the saiga have managed to
come back from the brink
in the long term however their survival
depends on whether the kazakh step is
left
as an untouched paradise
you